good morning nation my name is Evan
Carmichael my one word to believe as I
believe that entrepreneurs will solve
all of the world's major problems so
health ones your journey of today's
message is go work as mix dogs over to
you Robert Kiyosaki goes you wake up
tomorrow morning
and you're on the street and you have
nothing you don't have a single contact
and your network all you have is the
knowledge and experience that you've had
throughout your career how do you build
up from there well a Denver many times
so it's no big deal you just figure out
what's needed I'm wanted to go do it you
know I'll always kind of dump on we call
the fast-food industry if I had to do it
again I go work for McDonald's and the
reason I go work for McDonald's you know
whether it's seven bucks an hour or 15 I
don't really care I don't really like
McDonald's food but they have the best
business systems in the world how else
can a company take virtually non
college-educated people and build a
fast-food industry across the world and
they have the best system so right
inside little McDonald's you can learn
everything you need to learn about
business except for the management side
of it so I just go work it Donald so I
can learn even more so I look at life as
learning I'm constantly learning you
know reading constantly studying
constantly I spend most of my time with
entrepreneurs I don't spend my time with
people who complain about the economy
you know so nothing we really change I
just go back to being an entrepreneur if
you want to learn how to do something
the fastest way to do it is the goal
somebody who's already done now I'm not
a huge fan about working for a giant
corporation because after you are
assigned a specific task and you don't
really get the Explorer quickly but it
worked for somebody who's got a much
smaller company an entrepreneur then you
get to take on a lot more
responsibilities my appeal is I would
suggest that don't work for someone who
was 10 employees or less who's doing
exactly what you want to do and get as
close to the entrepreneur family
response you can hire to do whatever job
it is that you want to learn right but
then you get this close to the utterance
box take on more work work overtime work
extra hours because this doesn't work
this is your education you're getting
paid to learn instead of pain to go with
University you're getting paid to make
mistakes to learn how things are done to
understand business is easy understand
addition to being an industry that you
want to get into you're getting paid to
learn and that's the best that it was
doing and so when I sold my first
business as an example
I want one of over the counter I wanted
more not process how will the lot of
people who gone through it I didn't have
to raise money for my business we
thought about it we almost did it but we
got box before we need to go and do it
and so I was still the company want to
go work at a venture capital company and
I connected with these VCS who were for
Bevins or sixties or seventies they knew
the streets they had a wealth of
experience education and I helped them
bring in new lead and is a product that
I learned not just about the raising
capital industry the game how it works
where people look for what it all looks
like because I had zero concept and
everything did for my business but also
to see how they operate how they thought
about business the advices that gave the
entrepreneur one of my favorite
experiences was we got hired to
basically be a temporary chairman for a
company to go in and advise CEO
to do and every month we go in and look
at the numbers and have conversations
and guides and CEOs make better
decisions in her business and it was
awesome it was awesome to see how these
guys thought and a lot of what they
learned and taught I think that raises
the guys are doing what I want to learn
and so it's the fastest way to learn
whatever it is that you want to do if
you're uncertain if you education having
committed to getting going yet go work
for somebody who's done model or success
again for those teachers this is even an
industry you want to get into sometimes
we get into something realize odd you
know what I don't really like that we
want to do that and it's better to
figure it out working for somebody else
in to invest your all the time and money
and resources into it and - they look at
your past the students being mean is
struggling over and over and over and
over again they'll teach you how to do
it a lot more quickly and then I also
start working on the side I'd be
moonlighting I've been working part time
every I wanted way to be my own business
up on the side but learn from somebody
be various on accept what you want to do
I really want to practice ways to get to
where you want to go so the question say
today is I'm curious what is one of the
greatest lessons that you have learned
from somebody out if you apply to you
life or to your business recently like
in the past year the greatest lesson
where is the past year from somebody
that had a big impact in your life or
your business leave it down the comments
below really curious I also want to give
a quick shirt of conducing Thomas Jun
thank you so much begin at the top of my
books gear one word I really really
appreciate the support and I hope you
enjoyed through so thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I'll
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
and I'll see you again far more day for
another shot of its best away
all right so give me
when you cease to learn you cease to
grow when you cease to learn you sort of
begin to decay a little bit you are to
learn to how to stay healthy and you say
well how do I do that it will the proper
diet and exercise and rest that's part
of it there was
we're not healthy by accident it's by
learning some key things in life that
really make a difference and when we
keep learning something happens in a lie
for example you're not living in an age
when we've had to keep learning because
when I was born there were no computers
that I knew of in 1932 so we go back and
you look at your life and think about
all the things that you've had to learn
that your predecessors and your parents
didn't have to learn because they didn't
even exist so if you if you're going to
be useful all the days of your life
you've got to be willing to keep
learning so I would simply say that a
lazy brain is an aging brain you don't
want to learn what happens you start
decaying and so there's something
interesting and exciting about learning
things in life no matter who you are and
no matter what your age might be
sometimes when it's all about you like I
said like never get high on your own
supply right when it's all about you you
know like biggie says actually right or
actually Scarface if we go back all the
way to the original reference but you
know that you can't think that like
you're the only game in town that's a
really dangerous tall Frances man you
know collaborations good and it's
healthy and working with young cats that
are coming up and have their own revenge
fantasies yo we could learn from that
now I'm not too old for murder man I've
been going to school since I might not
have been in the classroom but schools
come to me like when you want to learn
school comes to you what is like the
number one thing to take from the ego is
the enemy and a piece of advice should
we give to you know a young Ryan holiday
now 19 20 years old that's watching this
right now yeah so I mean one of my
favorite sections of the book of this
idea of that you can never stop being a
student because students are humbled
because they understand that there's
someone above them who can teach them so
if you never stop being a student
there's a quote from epic to industry
says one cannot learn that which they
think they already know right and so if
you think you already know everything
you've stopped being the student and
you're not going to learn anymore and in
some ways it's over for you I was forced
to look at the world the way he looks at
the world like how I research books I
learned from Roberts system because as
his research assistant he wasn't like oh
go make up your own system he's like how
I do it you need to do it this way so
you can be of service to me and so
you're sort of learning how to do that
thing rather than like you know sitting
down and reading a book about it or
trying to learn a song by ear it's like
know somebody showed you how to do each
test